und zum phönix tagesgespräch bin ich
jetzt verbunden mit peter liese cdu erst
gesundheitspolitische sprecher für die
svp fraktion im europäischen parlament
herr lisa sie sind selbst mediziner
deswegen können wir zwar über impfen
auch reden aber etwas viel wichtigeres
steckt war sie nach dem impfen nämlich
das digitale im zertifikat daran
arbeiten die europäer im grunde genommen
eben gedanken
seit anfang des jahres am zwanzigsten
mal gab es wenn es nicht falsch nach
geschlagen habe die große einigung
zwischen dem parlament dem europäischen
rat wo stehen wir jetzt ja zunächst
einmal vor land denkt das impfen ist
schon das wichtigste dass zb gab es ja
nur eine möglichkeit nachzuweisen dass
man geimpft ist genesen oder negativ
getestet aber das ist eben auch wichtig
weil wir alle wieder freiheiten wollen
auch die reisefreiheit in europa aber
wir wollen nicht dass aus der reisewelle
eine infektionswelle wird wie das leider
im letzten jahr passiert ist und
deswegen haben wir uns in rekordzeit auf
einen text geeinigt zwischen
europäischen parlament und den
mitgliedstaaten und der europäischen
kommission und diese einigung wird heute
im europäischen parlament endgültig
geschlossen
damit das zertifikat am ersten
rechtskräftig für alle in europa in
kraft treten kann
dann müssten wir im grunde genommen
weiter fragen das ist ja technisch auch
ein sehr komplizierter prozess wenn ich
das richtig gelesen habe gibt es seit
ersten juni so etwas wie eine gemeinsame
plattform wo dann alle mitgliedsstaaten
die sich beteiligen dort andocken
wann wird dieses zertifikat also
verfügbar seien sie sagen erster juli
das zweite frage die sich anschließt
wäre was kann es dann tatsächlich also
wo liegt mein nutzwert ja der nutzwert
ist dass man einfacher als mit dem
gelben impfausweis durch einen qr-code
unkompliziert nachweisen kann dass man
vollständig geimpft ist ein negativen
test hat oder von der krankheit genesen
ist und für die gesellschaft ist der
nutzwert deshalb wichtig weil ein
solches zertifikat wesentlich schwerer
nur zu fälschen ist als der gelbe im
voraus weiß wenn wir leider auch
festgestellt dass mit dem im voraus weiß
schon versucht wird zu betrügen
dass man sich sozusagen illegal ins
ausweise besorgt das ist eine straftat
das sollte niemand tun aber ich hab
selber im impfzentrum mitgearbeitet und
infor ausweise ausgestellt
im wesentlichen ist das ja eine
unterschrift und einen stempel wenn es
gut läuft hat man noch die chargennummer
aber leider ist das alles sehr
betrugsanfällig und sind eben besser
geschützt als gesellschaft wenn es
fälschungssicher ist und wir haben auf
diesem zertifikat eben den qr-code den
muss man nicht auf dem handy haben man
kann ihn auch sich ausdrucken lassen auf
papier wenn man kann den die hat oder
das einfach aus anderen gründen nicht
auf dem handy haben will
aber da kann man dann nach kontrollieren
stimmt das wirklich ist dieser mensch
geimpft getestet oder genesen
das wäre jetzt meine nächste frage
gewesen gerade weil sie den gelben
impfpass den wir alle kennen der von der
whu anerkannt ist in jedem land dieser
erde noch ausführlich angesprochen haben
und auch natürlich diese vielen menschen
die in deutschland durchaus noch
aufgrund von jahrgang oder von anderen
skepsis die da ist noch im analogen
verharren also die würden dann mit dem
zettel an jeder grenze in europa mit
diesem ausgedruckten qr-code wirklich
gut bedient werden
da sind sie sicher ja das ist ganz
wichtig dass man eben nicht nur
diejenigen berücksichtigt die ein handy
haben und damit alltäglich umgehen gibt
auch menschen die sagen ich will ein
paar aus datenschutzgründen oder
sonstigen auf meinem handy so einen
qr-code nicht haben aber eben gerade
auch ältere die mit dem handy nicht so
vertraut sind
man kann diesen diesen qr-code sich
ausdrucken lassen entscheidend ist das
ist eben eine lösung ist die derjenige
der kontrolliert auch verbinden kann mit
der stelle die das zertifikat
ausgestellt hat so dass man erkennen
kann ist wirklich ein geimpfter vor mir
oder ein genesener und nicht jemand der
das vorgibt handy sind haben wir in
deutschland die besondere situation dass
wir ja seit dezember 2020 endet
aber impfen und anders als viele andere
staaten in europa das erstmal sie haben
das schön beschrieben fleißig mit diesem
kleinen sticker in den impfpass
eintragen das heißt wir haben jetzt
millionen von impfungen
wir sind ja jetzt bei über 40 millionen
impfung die wir nach digitalisieren
müssen
das kann doch so schnell unmöglich gehen
mal ganz abgesehen von der blamage dass
wir in deutschland wieder so hintendran
sind ja wir haben sicherlich viele
lehren aus der krise zu ziehen eine
lehre ist auch das ist mit der
digitalisierung im gesundheitswesen und
insgesamt schneller gehen muss besser
werden muss in deutschland
aber man kann diese impfausweise die
viele jetzt haben fast 50 prozent sind
erst geimpft etwa 20 prozent sind
vollständig geimpft die kann man
natürlich um tragen das kann man nicht
in den praxen machen wir haben im
beitrag ja sehr gut gezeigt dass die
medizinischen fachangestellten und die
ärztlichen kollegen ich rede auch viel
mit den mit den praxen vor ort in meinem
wahlkreis in süd west fallen
den kann man jetzt nicht zumuten dass
die patienten auch noch kommen und
dieses zertifikat haben wollen deswegen
redet die bundesregierung mit den
apotheken
da ist auch fachpersonal und dieses
fachpersonal könnte das zertifikat
ausstellen das ist sich ja nur die
zweitbeste lösung aber das ist denn
jetzt ein pragmatisches vorgehen das man
anderes fachpersonal nutzt um dieses
zertifikat auszustellen
elise sie haben eingangs unseres
gespräches und dann könnten wir das
hätten auch schön rund machen
festgestellt dass natürlich viel
wichtiger und schöner als das zertifikat
das eigentliche impfen ist also die
möglichkeit sich zu schützen vor wind 19
da in deutschland ich sage ihnen das
nichts neues
zwar die gefallene priorisierung aber
nach wie vor zu wenig impfstoff das
europäische parlament hatte sich
ziemlich scharf mit der europäischen
kommission auseinandergesetzt rund um
das impfstoff beschaffungsmanagement
gerade wo wir jetzt wissen dass diese
impfungen wahrscheinlich mutmaßlich
nicht so furchtbar lange halten wie
sieht es aus mit dem nachschub sind
diese fehler vom staat jetzt beseitigt
sind sozusagen genügend dinge jetzt
bestellt und in der pipeline
definitiv ja zunächst mal
muss man das alles ins verhältnis
stellen wenn man die ins geschwindigkeit
in den 30 größten ländern der welt
ansieht dann ist deutschland
mittlerweile auf platz drei in der eu
vorne und weit vor ländern wie japan
oder auch russland
woher manche den eindruck vermitteln als
ob russland die welt im könnte die sind
weit hinten dran aber nichts ist so gut
dass es nicht noch besser werden könnte
wir ärgern uns gerade das von johnson
johnson und biotech in diesen tagen
weniger impfstoff kommt als angekündigt
das wird bis ende des monats nochmal
besser und dann müssen wir uns noch alle
darauf vorbereiten
aber wir müssen vor allen dingen in der
tat wenn es um auffrischungsimpfungen
geht anders rangehen als im letzten jahr
bei der beschaffung des impfstoffs wer
jetzt eben zufällig kommt und da ist die
europäische kommission in der tat sehr
weit nach vorne gegangen und hat jetzt
schon 1,8 milliarden dosen für die
nächsten jahre bestellt damit wir wenn
wir durch mutationen oder andere
herausforderungen einfach die
auffrischungsimpfung brauchen dass das
dann sehr viel schneller geht und dass
wir diesen die sie heute morgen gezeigt
haben dann im nächsten und im
übernächsten jahr definitiv nicht
erleben werden okay wir können und
müssen noch besser werden mit kurven 19
aber bald haben wir das zertifikat dazu
und vielleicht auch die impfung wenn
alles gut läuft herzlichen dank für ihre
einschätzungen dem phoenix tagesgespräch
das war peter liese der
gesundheitspolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion im europäischen parlament ich
danke ihnen gerne